it is 6 24 on your wednesday morning got
a teeny tiny taste of things to come at
i-15 and tropicana so you think it's
tough getting through the rush hour
traffic in the 95 515 between the
spaghetti bowl and eastern nevada
department of transportation says hold
my beer well not in those words exactly
right but over the next few days you are
going to see construction cones on the
exit ramp from the south 15 to go west
on tropicana and over the next four
years you're going to expect big time
changes to both drop over the 15 as well
as the ramp areas around trop and that
includes replacing that flyover that
takes you from the south 15 to go east
on tropicana and over the next several
months you will be seeing overnight work
on shoulders ramps and some lane
closures on the 15 from flamingo all the
way down to warm springs all in
preparation for the makeover of the
entire area which will take place in
phases tentative completion mark your
calendar 2025.
now we have specifics on the short-term
work and links to stay up-to-date on the
big picture of ndot's i-15 trump project
on our website 8newsnow.com click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8 news now.com